se ha definido ya un objetivo ambicioso
de proteger el 30 por ciento de la
biodiversidad marina y terrestre de aquí
al 2030 los países ya han adoptado más
de 100 propuestas antes de la apertura
oficial de la cumbre como por ejemplo
para proteger a los grandes simios
más aún más allá de la cumbre tiene como
objetivo de poner en foco la pérdida de
biodiversidad y la protección de la
naturaleza que de manera general no
recibe el mismo nivel de atención por
parte de los líderes mundiales como
podría ser el caso por ejemplo del
cambio climático entonces el objetivo
para los países será de ponerse de
acuerdo en un marco de acción para poder
implementar medidas pero también se
espera que podrán contribuir con aporte
financiero la unión internacional de la
protección de la naturaleza ha exhortado
a los líderes mundiales de redistribuir
un paquete de estímulo global de kobe 19
que alcanza más y trillones de dólares
para que al menos el 10% sea asignado
para la protección de la naturaleza